[Music]
hi I'm Dan fan I'm actually here at the
project catapult booth where we're
actually making available FPGAs and a
network configuration for academic
researchers to use and so we have a
partnership with Intel and we have these
deployed down at UT Austin at the attack
Advanced Computing Center and we invite
people to actually test it out and
accelerate the research so one of the
things we have is these the FPGAs which
are you can burn down to them they run
at the line of a hardware speed so they
run really fast take not too much power
and we have these deployed down there
connected with these what are called our
torus connectors so they're all directly
connected to point point from each of
these cards but it allows you to
actually have fast speed that doesn't
have to go out to the CPU and execute so
just as a quick short little demo we
have a receiver that we have running on
this node and this is running down
attack so one of the things I wanted to
do is actually set this node up these
are both running down at the UT Austin
at the Tech Center this node up as a
receiver and so it'll sit on the network
one of these cables waiting for
information and then I'll set this one
up as a as the transmitter and what
you're seeing is it's sending about
eight gigs of data very quickly over
this link being processed by the FPGA
and so we can do it in about seven
seconds fairly fairly quickly so one
just thank you for taking a look at the
catapult and hope please come and join
us it's at a k-8 microsoft.net slash
catapult - academic